fires raged in the blue mountains for a
week
now emergency response crews are moving
on to other blazers
individual residents here have been
allowed to return home
stephen close is one of them he's
searching for possessions that survived
the blaze
yes of course yeah yeah we'd reboot yeah
we've we've lived here for 30
33 years and so we've never had our
house destroyed before so
i figure if we've got another 33 years
we should be right
warnings haven't been lifted everywhere
temperatures and winds have dropped but
dozens of blazers are still out of
control
thousands of firefighters have been
mobilized to battle the flames
on land and from the air
a water bombing plane crashed into a
national park south of sydney killing
the pilot
officials said the wreckage caught fire
kindling yet another fire
investigations are underway into what
caused the other fires
officials blamed some on negligent
behavior or lightning
but the biggest was triggered by the
australian military and a live
firing exercise on army land